I have a story for you that sounds like
satire or a Saturday Night Live skit
some of the world's worst authoritarian
dictators got together to discuss peace
wait a second what are you talking about
yes Vladimir Putin ran a peace summit
with Syrian dictator Bashar al-assad
Turkish authoritarian president air
dhawan and Iranian president rouhani now
to be clear I'm for peace obviously but
the idea that these individuals are
going to be the arbiters for a real
peace a humanitarian peace is utterly
laughable Assad and air Dewan are
currently overseeing some of the most
oppressive regimes in the world and
specifically the discussion was about
ending the Syrian civil war which has
been going on for six years at this
point and it says likely that Assad and
air Dewan are going to be part of some
major regional peace agreement that
would actually be real peace again
humanitarian peace it's about as likely
as right-wing Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu being an arbiter of
serious israeli-palestinian peace as
I've said for a year that's never going
to happen and this is never going to
happen I was thinking of another analogy
for this it's like if we decided hey
we're going to fix the issue of sexual
assault and sexual predator sexually
predatory behavior by putting Bill Cosby
Roy Moore and Donald Trump in a room to
fix the problem it's just it doesn't
make any sense it's not going to happen
and more than likely and we already know
I mean one of the first bits of
information that came out of this peace
summit I almost can't say it without
gagging is that any so-called agreement
that results from this is going to leave
Bashar al-assad in charge in Syria and
as a sort of side note the idea of
putting in Vladimir Putin as an arbiter
is laughable Russia has been involved
militarily in Syrian sort of a
repression against the opposition there
under the guise of fighting Isis for
years and now you're going to put Putin
in as the referee I mean down to the
smallest details this seems like an
utter and total joke and and by the way
this is exactly the type of thing that
the trump presidency enables right Trump
throughout the Thanksgiving holiday was
busy tweeting about lies about Time
magazine's Person of the Year and for
the last couple of months busy with
things like pulling out of the Paris
climate Accords and whatever else
meanwhile Vladimir Putin is running
meetings and in fact Vladimir Putin
called Donald Trump after this so-called
peace summit to inform him of the
results and there's a really sad thing
which is that there's a strain of the
left that absolutely loves this they
love a lot of these guys they see this
and they think it's great and I've
identified the strain of the left before
I I don't know exactly what to call them
but it's the same strain of the left
that loved Hugo Chavez that loves
Nicolas Maduro now in Venezuela that
likes or at least as sort of
indifference to Vladimir Putin that that
even defended dictator Robert Mugabe
last week when he was ousted from power
in Zimbabwe there are people on the
ostensible left who when Mugabe was
removed and ultimately agreed to
relinquish the presidency in Zimbabwe
there were people on the Left saying
don't fall for the corporate narrative
that Mugabe was this dictator because
it's just playing into American
colonialism abroad I am the first to
admit that the United States has been
party to some really horrible forced
regime change and meddling not only in
Africa but in South America as well and
being from Argentina I'm very familiar
with that but going from that to the
defense of an anti-democratic
authoritarian dictator like Mugabe or
whoever is going completely off the deep
end and I'm against it and I've always
been against it and I will continue to
be against it agree or disagree with me
you know that I am NOT toeing any
particular line on that
because III think that the right is
horrible on this issue but there's the
strain of the left that is misguided as
well in any case I apologize for the
rant but I await the big news of Middle
Eastern peace Syrian peace brokered by
Assad and air Dewan I'm all ears right I
hope it happens but put me in the
skeptical camp if you want to discuss
this issue or any other issues that we
have talked about on the program or
political stories that are going on join
us on our subreddit at david pakman.com
slash reg1 be back after this lots to
catch up on after the Thanksgiving break
today's program is made possible in part
by movement watches movement gets it
right holiday shopping can be tough it's
annoying but thanks to movement all of
the gift-giving anxiety can disappear by
pressing a button the watches from MVM t
I am actually wearing mine today people
love this watch they are really great
gifts for just about anybody in your
life and they start at just 95 dollars
you've heard me talk about movement I'm
sure that by now you have a watch but
you can finish your holiday shopping by
getting a movement watch for somebody
else on your list skip the lines I hate
driving to the mall I hate the parking
lots I hate the entire thing and these
watches although they look like they
should cost four to five hundred dollars
in a department store start at just 95
bucks over a million watches sold in
over a hundred and sixty countries and
you can get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns at MVM t.com
/pa que ma n go to nvm t.com slash
Pakman and check out what's available